people interaction I'm real weird
because I don't care I'll be alone and
not care to be totally stoked whatever
sitting there playing guitar writing a
book just doing anything alone I'm fine
don't care yes you are weird or I can be
with people hanging out and I'm fine I'm
not it doesn't uh use energy or anything
like that no look you take that to the
extreme sometimes you can be like all
right I I guess maybe this leads me
towards introvert a little bit but you
take it to an extreme where you got a
thing and there's a bunch of people then
you really don't want to be around a
bunch of people so I guess that's a
little bit of makes me a little bit of a
of an introvert a little bit more but
I'd actually but I actually don't care